Con una población de algo más de 30
millones de habitantes, el Perú, una de
las tierras más bellas del mundo, es el
cuarto país más grande de
Latinoamérica y una de las naciones con
más biodiversidad y recursos naturales
de todo el planeta.
En este extenso país andino, podemos
encontrar, entre otros muchos recursos
naturales, las mayores reservas de plata,
las terceras mayores reservas de cobre y
zinc o las sextas de oro de todo el
mundo.
En este vídeo hablamos de Perú.
El Perú sigue siendo un país pobre y aún
son muchas las carencias que, sin duda,
presenta su marco institucional, pero, pese
a ello, este país destaca entre sus
países vecinos latinoamericanos como un
ejemplo de buenas reformas. Y ya hay quien
incluso afirma que, de continuar este
proceso, en poco tiempo nos referiremos a
Perú como una gran potencia latina. Tan
sólo Lima, su capital tiene ya un
Producto Interno Bruto cuatro veces
superior al de Bolivia. -"Evolución
económica". Perú han registrado en la última
década la segunda mayor tasa de
crecimiento económico de toda
Latinoamérica.
En este mismo periodo, su PIB se ha más
que duplicado, la inversión ha pasado
del 13% del PIB e a más del 20,
y el índice pobreza, esto es el porcentaje de
personas que no tienen cubiertas las
necesidades esenciales de alimentación,
abrigo, educación y atención médica, se
ha reducido de cotas superiores al 50% en
el año 2000 al entorno del 22% hoy en
día. Menos de la mitad.
¡No está mal! - "El Perú es el país que
más redujo la pobreza en América
Latina en los últimos 13 años."
y ¡ojo! El Perú es uno de los países más
saneados de toda latinoamérica e
incluso del mundo. Gracias a una decidida
responsabilidad en el uso del dinero
público,
un logro, por cierto,  compartidos por
los últimos gobiernos de Ollanta Humala,
Alan García y Alejandro Toledo, la deuda
pública se ha reducido a menos de la
mitad desde el año 2000 y hoy supone poco
más del 20% del PIB
Pero ¿cómo surgió la prosperidad?
o, mejor dicho, ¿cómo se alcanzó
semejante consenso político en torno a
la responsabilidad presupuestaria y las
políticas pro mercado?
Pues bien, éste sin duda el punto más
interesante y donde el Perú nos
traslada una valiosa enseñanza.
Hace poco, en VisualPolitik, hablamos
sobre el desastre de Venezuela, pues bien
la década de los 80 fue para el Perú aún
peor.
Veamos qué ocurrió.
- "Crisis de los 80."
En la década de los 70 y en la primera mitad
de los 80, los gobiernos peruanos
apostaron por impulsar la economía a
través de la inversión estatal y la
sustitución de las importaciones
limitando la compra de productos
extranjeros. Para lograrlo tuvieron que
pedir muchos préstamos lo que disparó
la deuda pública. Los resultados fueron tan
pobres que cuando en el 79se produjo la
crisis del petróleo y se ralentizó
con ello el crecimiento económico
internacional y la demanda de materias
primas, el gobierno del Perú comenzó a
tener tantos problemas que en 1983
suspendió pagos, es decir, dejó de pagar
las deudas porque se quedó sin dinero.
En otras palabras, el gobierno de Perú
quebró. A partir de ahí la cosa fue de
mal en peor y con la llegada de Alan
García al poder, en 1985, el desastre
fue ya casi total. El gobierno comenzó a
intervenir masivamente en la fijación
de precios y en el mercado laboral,
reforzó las políticas que tenían como
objetivo sustituir las importaciones,
limitando la cantidad de productos que
se podían comprar y estableciendo un
arancel medio que llegó al nivel del
66%.
- " Ahora sí siento que estamos haciendo una
revolución,
siento que estamos luchando por la justicia."
El déficit público estába por las nubes
y la economía informal era la norma
habitual, con lo que, a pesar de existir
más de cien tributos, el estado apenas
lograba recaudar impuestos. Y cómo
además había suspendido pagos y nadie
le prestaba dinero ¿que hizo? Pues comenzó
a imprimir más y más dinero,
convirtiendo al Inti, en aquel entonces
la divisa peruana, en una moneda con
prácticamente el mismo valor que el
dinero del monopoly.
Por si fuese poco, el narcotráfico y el
terrorismo de los grupos Sendero
Luminoso y el Movimiento Revolucionario
Tupac Amarut, el MRTA,  se extendieron
por el país causando decenas de miles
de muertos. "- El MRTA ubica su centro de
operaciones en la zona de la selva
nororiental y busca una alianza
estratégica con las bandas de
narcotraficantes."
El resultado de todo ello fue que al
final de la década el PIB había
desplomado un 25 por ciento; el pib per
cápita se situaba en los niveles de 1960; la
inflación anual superó el 7 mil 500 por
cien en 1990 y el Banco Mundial
reconoció a Perú como uno de los
países más pobres del mundo. - "Año 85
¿cuanto contaba un kilito de frejoles?
seis intis nada más.
Ahí entró Alan ¿eh? Con seis intis compraba suficientes frijoles.
Cuando terminó Alan en el año
90 ¿cuánto costaba un kilo de frijoles?
122.300 intis, un kilo de frijol."
Bueno, él desastre fue de tal magnitud
que el Banco Mundial calcula que, de no
haberse producido, el pib per cápita en
paridad de poder adquisitivo del Perú
sería hoy equivalente al de países
como Italia, España o Corea del Sur.
¡Casi nada! Si os fijáis, en cierto modo, la
crisis fue similar a la que hoy vive
Venezuela: mucho gasto público, muchos
impuestos, impresión de más y más
moneda, violencia y caída en el precio
de las materias primas.
Precisamente, cuando hicimos el video
sobre la crisis en Venezuela, muchos nos
preguntasteis que haríamos para salir
de la crisis, pues bien hoy vamos a ver
qué hizo Perú.
- "Camino a la prosperidad".
En 1990 dio comienzo un intenso plan de
reformas y estabilización económica
que, prácticamente, podemos decir, se ha
alargado hasta nuestros días y que ha
pasado por los siguientes puntos: Para frenar la inflación se sustituyó la moneda
nacional en vigor, el Inti, por una nueva
moneda,
el nuevo sol, y se permitió, en la
práctica, la dolarización de la
economía.
La estabilidad monetaria pasó desde ese momento
a ser una prioridad nacional.
Se reformuló y simplificó todo el sistema
tributario suprimiendo más de 64 impuestos.
Se reestructuró el sistema de
pensiones, tomando como modelo el sistema
de capitalización chileo, aunque eso
sí, introduciendo numerosas mejoras.
Por cierto,  de este tema tan
controvertido hablaremos muy pronto.
Se puso en marcha un intenso programa de
atracción de inversión extranjera y
privatización de empresas públicas. En
poco tiempo, empresas como la Compañía
Peruana de Teléfonos, Aeroperú o
Electrolima, pasaron a la competencia privada.
Se aprobó una estrategia de
apertura comercial que se ha traducido
en la reducción del arancel medio
desde el increíble 66% al entorno del 1,5
al tiempo que se han firmado
numerosos tratados de libre comercio,
incluyendo uno con estados unidos y otro
con la unión europea. En 2002 comenzó
una paulatina descentralización del
poder, de tal forma que hoy la mayor
parte de la inversión pública
corresponde ya a las regiones y a los
municipios. Y por último, el punto tal
vez más destacado, la apuesta por el
equilibrio presupuestario que han
mantenido todos los gobiernos desde
entonces.
De hecho en 1999 se
aprobó la llamada Ley de Prudencia
y Transparencia Fiscal, que limita el
poder discrecional de los
gobiernos para gastar más de lo que se
ingresa, e introduce elementos correctores en
situaciones de déficit público. No son
pocos los expertos que afirman que ésta ha
sido la ley más importante de la historia moderna del Perú. Desde luego gracias a ellas
los superávits públicos no resultan
extraños en él Perú. - "Perú registró un
superávit fiscal del 7% en el primer
trimestre del año,
esto como consecuencia del aumento de
los ingresos del gobierno y un
crecimiento económico sostenido." Es
verdad,
en los años 90 Perú también tuvo su
lado de sombras, no penséis  que nos
hemos olvidado del autoritarismo de
Alberto Fujimori un Presidente que hoy
está cumpliendo una condena de 25 años
por crímenes contra humanidad y delitos
de corrupción.
Bueno, como veis, y aquí me refiero en especial a todos nuestros amigos venezolanos,
por mal que estén las cosas siempre
hay salida.  - "El Perú, hoy y mañana."
Pero, ¿por qué Perú es todavía un país
pobre? Cómo dijimos al principio, son aún
muchas las carencias institucionales y
los retos a los que se enfrenta la
nación andina.
Entre ellos podemos destacar la elevada
corrupción y la inseguridad jurídica,
algo que por ejemplo podemos ver con el
caso de los escuadrones de la muerte.
También la altísima delincuencia, la
elevada burocracia y el riesgo de que la
industria minera conlleve los mismos
problemas de corte rentista que hoy sufre Chile.
Por no olvidar el gran contraste en
el nivel de vida que existe entre las
diferentes regiones.
Precisamente el pasado 5 de junio de
2016, se celebró la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales, por la que
fue elegido Pedro Pablo Kuczynski como
nuevo Presidente de la República.
Estas elecciones fueron, por cierto, las
más reñidas de la historia y Kuczynski
se impuso a su adversaria, Keiko Fujimori,
hija de Alberto Fujimori, por poco
más de 40 mil votos. Entre los objetivos
anunciados por Kuczynski está continuar
la agenda de impulso a la competitividad
y la apertura comercial.
Así, por ejemplo, ha prometido reducir al
10 por ciento el impuesto sobre
beneficios para las pymes, para las
pequeñas y medianas empresas; combatir
la burocracia, eliminando de forma
tajante
las regulaciones innecesarias; y apostar por
consolidar el proyecto de integración
conocido como Alianza del Pacífico.
Si Kuczynski consigue, a pesar de la
relativa debilidad política a la que se
enfrenta con un congreso no precisamente
amigo, mantener el timón y combatir los
problemas que afectan al Perú, estoy
convencido de que el crecimiento de la nación
andina continuará estando a la cabeza
de América Latina y puede que, en pocos
años, Perú, una nación joven cuya
población tiene una media de edad de apenas 27
años, logre emular el desarrollo de los
llamados dragones asiáticos y
transformarse en una importante potencia.
¿Qué pensáis vosotros? ¿Logrará Perú
dejar atrás la pobreza y convertirse en
toda una potencia? ¿Es Kuczynski la
persona idónea para lograrlo? Esperamos vuestros comentarios, si os ha gustado el
vídeo darle a like y suscribiros al canal si aun no lo habéis hecho ya.
Hasta la próxima amigos, o como diríamos en quechua: